June 9th Chris Harrison officiating
you're getting married in paradise what
other details do we need to know what's
plan it's a black and white party bring
your best and I mean energy it's gonna
be a good time we got to slice the cake
waiting for everyone give me a lot of
mashed potatoes you know probably some
cheese pizza I guess you know it's to me
a good time you might see me drop out of
a helicopter you know it's all happening
in Paradise dance routine oh yeah it's
gonna be a party I wouldn't expect
anything less from you to Joe I can't
wait to hear your speech Jordan it'll
yes oh so you guys are gonna get married
on TV this is for sure happening this is
happening yeah and why was that
important to you you met in paradise
tell me what you're thinking
you know I owe it to like the the
franchise you know they brought us
together to have them witnesses I mean
we I just started this journey what six
months ago and Here I am right now with
you and it's it just blows my mind that
we went on a TV show we found each other
and it's so real it blows your mind I
mean it's I have to say Jordan I think
people are and I loved you on
Bachelorette but I've been so surprised
to see this other side of you is this
kind of wild did you even expect this
from yourself no I of course this is
this is me this is what I wanted people
to know about me and I'm glad it's being
shown I'm glad that you came and pulled
the best out of it yeah I mean I could
see I could see it from the beginning
tell me real quickly what it is about
each of you that made you know this
person was the one like how did you know
Jordan was the wife so the way that he
pulled all of my like vulnerabilities
out and made me think that it was worth
it to really let him in and fall and
they gives me so much security the way
that he speaks to me the way that we
talk about the future and his motivation
to just to just be successful while
loving me letting me be by his side like
the whole time I look forward to that
everything about him excites me Jordan
how did you know Jenna was the one Oh
whenever she walked up the steps into
paradise I looked into her eyes from a
distance I saw her soul am I still in
her soul they kind of just we linked up
like like Wi-Fi at a cafe
you know and it's been like that ever
since so wild it really is it's a
feeling that we're in the presence of
love at first sight it's going crazy
especially on a parity show you know
it's it's something that's supposed to
be funny and you look at our intros and
a lot people don't take it very
seriously but now the show takes a turn
for you know more romantic view and
there's it's the best story that I think
that's ever come out of paradise a lot
of people do go on the show get engaged
and then things don't like come to
fruition out of it how will you guys
kind of beat that reality show curse and
stay away from that you've just got to
be open and honest with each other be
transparent and let each other know that
hey like this is I'm gonna do this and
we've got to do it and that's that's
really just akin to your work and I
think it's not having these unrealistic
expectations is we know that we're going
to go through issues but it's gonna be
totally worth it in the end
baby steps all the way up to the top
[Music]